what a plug it's me in a meeting that
I'm about to have but just continue
today in Iraq and what a lot of people
have a have a really interesting vibe
today
no d-roc cuz a lot of meetings that I
couldn't go to plus you know kind of a
saddened heart a little bit with all the
news out of Vegas and so
[Music]
[Music]
if you actually don't give a [ __ ] the
way I didn't of what people think about
you all through your 20s like you just
don't care like you literally don't and
you just build something for yourself if
you have a much better chance just close
your eyes just close your eyes 29 in
Chicago just got a bunch of meetings
done in Detroit just enjoying the day
enjoying it with people I appreciated
having people meetings and debates and
I'm just grinding through gonna flip it
on d-roc productive day fine harwood
it's pure Wow gonna do well oh I turned
it off so you never post it all day my
heart was hurting it my stomach is empty
didn't feel it but just want to jump on
it very simply saying I love you guys so
much the engagement of everything going
on with you guys on the CM and the
emails tweets really lifted my spirits
nation just really appreciate you
YouTube thanks for watching thanks for
commenting makes feedback Tom Petty just
passed away what a legend Tom Petty you
see that on my man
thank you just keep saying hi everyone
I'm [ __ ] flattered as [ __ ] don't ever
be shy just or give me a head nod like
if you see I'm busy with a family or
something little head nod
I like winking you've seen it team human
grabber I have so much love for the
human
just grinding through and just really
want to take another second this is
gonna be just a [ __ ] love fest but it
is what it is gonna make sure that you
guys know how much I have love for all
of you literally brushing my teeth and
wanting to make sure that you guys know
I love you every day is different that's
why you vlog just one is sending my
appreciation wish you the best and for
another fun moment who's your favorite
Nick Ryan my favorite Nick right now
Frank Frenchy writes big thanks man and
CEO pol he likes our point guard I feel
this really meant to be I know I gotta
chase my dreams of universes there's any
thesis I believe in more than anything
it's happened culture it's understanding
what people give a [ __ ] about and
figuring out how to penetrate it and
bring value to it and the way I always
start is I'm always trying to find
people that are authentic to it
understand it understand the origin
stories where it came from have been
part of it
I did that with social media with Kevin
rose and others I've done that wine with
you know Bobby catcher and and Noah Bass
and others and when I look at
cryptocurrency and specifically eSports
that's what I want to do and I've spent
some time with some great people but for
me the hecto meeting was super exciting
because I know who's ingrained in it
authentic to it and a good dude plus had
a ton of context for me those are the
kind of meetings I want to take and
that's what really propelled me to take
the meeting and really the excitement I
went into that meeting
yeah man my man real pleasure was here
man I'm gonna drop off my bags to be
down in one second honestly of course
but you but you go with who you go with
people sitting on the couch right now
overthinking who their perfect partner
is like get somebody who's right yeah
and like [ __ ] go and be prepared to
make up for the shortcomings if they're
there Oh hundred thousand percent
ultimate it's up to you right wait what
what yeah holy that boy whether
something fails for not it it's
ultimately up to you I like people that
have been around a thing for a while and
we're coming they're out of patience the
right way you know I'll get we'll get to
know each other better
you travel a lot I do man you have a
family I do did my wife and Olivia seven
years old thousand five dogs by five my
favorite number for you by the way real
quick well I've got YouTube the reason I
do this in pictures is fives my favorite
number
I didn't mind sacrificing seconds and
not receiving a ton of cash during those
years we were building something your
patient yeah
pushes yes so what did I come into your
world about a year ago I was watching
ice that's why uh-huh because I started
to blog into the reason that I started
bladvic long it was because two things I
wanted to inspire my players by invite
acting up I couldn't I couldn't bring
myself to say well you got to do this if
you weren't doing it yeah cuz their
excuse was always like I'm competing I'm
a professional I'm busy
yes and I was like well it doesn't take
that long for you to connect with
and maybe build a friend that's been
that's been the most fun for me like
nobody's out working me and I'm doing it
now I've got D rocks keep you're really
doing it I'm respect that but even like
today like I don't know do rock have I
Steve seven thousand times ready today I
know we haven't been filming a lot but
like the way I'm feeling head cold right
now like 99% of people are laying in bed
out tomorrow yeah you know I you know
just either gonna will yourself to
victory or not you know this beautiful
about that is that when I what I used to
work at AIG we'd be home
I would I would dread getting up at yeah
8:30 to be at work at 9:00 because I was
that close now I can't I wake up I wake
up with my eyes open up dude if I felt
like the way I feel right now I'd be out
of school the rest of the week like dead
you know cuz I would let myself I would
my brain would let myself go to that
real fever place you know like right now
I'll fight it and I'll do everything
right water and watch hey I'll do
everything right I'll fight and I had to
wake up at 4:30 this morning like are
you kidding when you love it anyway so
you're watching Casey you know when I
talk about arrangement I'm sorry
that's right man tell you something man
this year I went from in real estate
I went from last year selling like 15
properties to 57 this year and I want
almost every day thank you you're
welcome buddy let me get a selfie with
you I love a man sorry sweetie what's
your name
yeah see oh nice to meet you man real
pleasure like your sweater man and your
beard - listen these sports is a beast
it's a monster it's just it hasn't even
started has the mister everybody in this
place right now if you're like esports
esports like yes some people other
people like what there's not a soul in
this hotel in a decade that's like what
is this and by the way I live in what's
called social media yeah
I started making videos on YouTube in
February of 2006
I think I uploaded for beauty video like
you know you know I mean yeah it's so
like bro when you would you ask that
goes I don't want to get too detailed
I'll sing the shower I was listening to
your left
and we JV it up because like who here
remembers the world before the internet
on the shampoo yeah man that's why we
know how big it is wouldn't wouldn't it
what are yours gonna what's that where's
yours come on mine's gonna air in two
days right three days you take whatever
you want
it's all yours better works partner you
better try things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
cuz that slows you down and it doesn't
beat you to I changed that thumbnail i
won Calvin I told you